this is a quick demonstration of recent
enhancements in our genome data viewer
including several tract graph settings
and the ability to apply settings to all
tracks in a composite track hub even
though today's examples use the genome
data viewer these enhancements also
apply to other ncbi resources that
incorporate the sequence viewer such as
snip and gene starting on the gdv home
page use the Browse genome button to go
into the current human assembly grch38
then in the tracks menu use configure
track hubs and connect to the blueprint
epigenomics hub
which you see is a composite track I've
already selected a few of the bigwig
tracks but notice that you can adjust
some track settings right here in this
hub configuration menu including an
option to apply these settings to the
entire group I'll hit configure and
these tracks load in the viewer
I used the Search Widget to go to the
region of the RCC one gene mostly just
to zoom in a bit and let's say you want
a cleaner view of the peaks in this
middle track which now has a maximum
value of 4.3 in the default linear scale
click on the track name or you can also
just hover on the track name then click
on the gear icon in the tool tip menu
that appears I'll change to a line graph
and set the value range from 1 to 4 for
this linear scale notice that this menu
includes the option to apply these
settings to the entire blueprint group
we even indicate where the data have
been clipped in the newly set range note
the red region to show a few more
features I'll go back to the configure
track hubs menu to connect to a
different hub and select two tracks that
display is a merged track
here's that track which combines data
for both splice donor and splice
acceptor predictions in green and red
respectively but you can now separate
them into individual tracks by choosing
the stacked view
you can also change the color scheme in
what we call a subtract if I click on
the green side the menu opens with that
track selected but you can change the
color and other settings for both tracks
in this menu
you can also hide one of the tracks
to recover that subtract go back into
the menu select the hidden subtract and
uncheck hide subtract
that's it for this demonstration you can
review these new features and a post to
our blog NCBI insights and as always
we'd love to have your feedback in
questions feedback is right here at the
bottom of the page and for questions
please use our support center